good for the climate
but it is also good for our independence
and good for our security of supply and
it creates jobs at home
so for this plan
every power eu
we have been discussing with the council
european council we are proposing to
support it with 300 billion euros from
eu funding there are different
parts that are contributing to this
funding if there are any questions about
me i'm very happy to respond to them but
this is the house of repower eu that we
have presented and discussed today
basically it is solidarity and
cooperation that are at the heart of any
successful strategy to deal
with russia as a non-reliable supplier
anymore
cooperation for example as has been
demonstrated by denmark germany the
netherlands and belgium
who
a couple of days ago
showed at a joint wind summit what it
means to develop develop the wind power
the offshore wind power in the north sea
and of course solidarity this was a big
topic today ensuring that in case of a
full disruption of gas flows from russia
gas is indeed allowed to flow to
wherever it is needed in europe
the second topic
was this defense
the war again
wasn't is a stark reminder
for our member states on the need to
strengthen our defense capacities
we have seen positive developments
notably of course we are all aware of
finland and sweden's application to join
nato nato the strongest military
alliance in the world
and they will benefit greatly from their
membership
but also the fact that since the
beginning of the war
leaders and the member states stepped up
and announced by now 200 billion euros
in extra military spending
now it is important that we ensure that
these
stepping up and additional investment
we get the maximum value out of it
and we all know the challenges that
exist
within the european union or the
european model
on one hand it is the lack of of
investment over the last year so the
gaps have to be filled
but the bigger challenge is the
fragmentation we have within the
european defense industry and the
duplication of weapon systems
here we see that this leads to increased
cost to reduce interoperability
so we have to improve this situation
and therefore it is first of all helpful
that since the beginning of this mandate
the european defense fund is up and
running it's a strong incentive to work
together
the pilot programs so far
have benefited to more than 600 entities
and 26 member states have used so far
the european defense fund this is an
encouraging start
but there's also a second element now
when we replenish
the military material that has been sent
to ukraine for example
it is important that this is coordinated
and for that we are setting up a task
force
to coordinate also to deconflict the
replenishment of the national stockpiles
and the commission will propose before
end of june to mobilize 500 million
euros over the next two years from the
eu budget to incentivize
the joint procurement by at least three
member states
this is let's say a pilot for a longer
term proposal that will come
in the course of this year for a
european defense investment program
finally
the third topic uh was on food security
charles introduced in the whole topic
already
at the moment being we're facing one
overriding urgency and that is 20
million tons of wheat are stuck in
ukraine and they have to get out
and therefore we have created and we're
working hard on the solidarity lines
lanes
that will enable it to bring out parts
of this wheat through land route and
trains towards our parts
it is not trivial
and it is of course more tedious and
expensive but it is necessary to get
this wheat out
the second point that is important that
we now give relief to the vulnerable
populations and um
the possibility to afford the food
for that we have pledged two and a half
billion euros
and we mobilize we propose to mobilize
reserves from the european development
fund to support for example sub-saharan
africa
the third element in that is that we
step up our own food production
we expect a record export of cereals of
40 million tons in 22 and 23.
and within this scenario
we call on all partners not to restrict
global trade on agricultural products
so any kind of trade restrictions have
absolutely no place in our member states
or globally
and finally
but this is the mid and long term we
really have to develop
better strategies uh for example in
north africa and sub-saharan africa to
increase the production and the
resilience with new technologies
precision farming the nanotechnologies
that out there so a lot of topics that
are combined to this food topic
from the urgency to the mid and to the
long term
we will coordinate all our actions with
the team europe approach
to feed into this work
i will travel to cairo mid-june
to discuss all these issues with
president al-sisi
because we have to look at them not only
from a european ukraine perspective but
also from a regional and bilateral
perspective many things
thank you madam presidents
of with export from from ukraine do you
see any chances that all these
solidarity lines and calls for the eu
member states to
for help in the export could add up to
the capacity sufficient for exporting
ukrainian with this year this this this
summer
uh if not because it seems for now it's
too too too little what should be your
comment on these ideas of of
transporting the wheat
through belarus
uh on the price of it through various
baltic states and if not do you see any
diplomatic possibility to
convince or to make
russians to to unblock odessa or to
export the wheat thank you now you are
absolutely right it should be the the
first priority because uh there are 22
millions of tons of drains that are
blocked in ukraine especially in odessa
and a few weeks ago when i went to this
site the occasion to see with my own ice
was the situation on the ground and for
instance countries like egypt and other
countries
in africa
they are victims of this this situation
it means that we fully support all the
efforts made by the united nations in
order to find an agreement uh to open a
maritime corridor to the black through
the black sea it would be the best
option in that to make sure it is
possible to export grains but we are not
certain we are certain it will work we
hope it will be possible to get an
agreement on that important topic and
that's why we are also working based on
the proposal of the commission on
those
green lanes
in order to facilitate alternative
routes and with the leaders uh today and
yesterday we discussed the different
possibilities in order to develop
alternative routes but we know that it's
more difficult it's more expensive it's
more difficult for obvious logistic
reasons
and we try to facilitate uh
in order to in order to uh to reduce the
initiative burdens which also which is
also an important question about belarus
and the access uh towards the baltic sea
uh we understand that there were also
tolls at the level of the united nations
on that uh on that topic
and we support all these efforts but
in the short term we don't see a
concrete concrete result a concrete
achievement and you know that we have
decided uh sanctions on belarus on the
on the protection the fertilizers for
instance and we finns is very important
to maintain the pressure against the
kremlin but also against belarus because
we feel that this country is helping a
lot uh russia uh in the in in the
framework of this war launched by russia
against ukraine yeah
only little to add um
shal described indeed our
efforts or the international efforts in
the black sea
it is important not to underestimate the
work we can do now and we're doing now
indeed these 20 million tons are there
on average ukraine exported in normal
times 5 million tons per month
now we are at least at a range between
200 000 and 1 million ton per month with
these measures of the green lanes for
example very tedious very difficult
lots of effort but it's something you
can do right now and we are doing right
now while the other efforts for the
bigger picture of course are still
ongoing
yuri you are next
uh yes thank you very much yuri chico
ukrainian service of deutsche welle uh i
have a question first from about the uh
embargo on oil
uh it of course is great that the you
reach this deal but
if you look at the message it sends to
russia it looks like it says to russia
that russia has still time six eight
more months to continue destroying
ukraine till the embargo starts
enters into force
and it says like russia has all this
time in order to find other buyers for
this oil so my question is uh which
message do you see it sends to
russia and how it helps to stop war now
and the second question is also because
you discussed today a lot of
energy uh what do you see ukraine is
connected to
uh european continental electricity grid
already for a couple of months
and i know that the work is going on the
commercial of selling of ukraine and
electricity to the eu countries so which
perspective do you see i think it's
rather to
have on the line question which
perspective do you see here how
soon it might start this
commercial trade of electricity with
ukraine and how can it help also europe
in its energy transition thank you very
much i think it was an outstanding
success that we were able to connect the
electricity grid that fast
you must know that
in february and february beginning of
march there was a planned
decoupling
of the ukrainian electricity grid from
the russian electricity grid with
initially the plan to recouple again and
take two years to then join the european
union
of course when the war hit it was
absolutely impossible to recouple
ukraine to the russian grid
and we managed within two weeks
to couple the ukrainian grid to the
european european one and this was and
is a big success
and therefore um i think it also shows
that we have ongoing war work during the
war
that always um improves and supports the
situation of ukraine so it's very
important not only to stare at the war
which is atrocious and horrible
but to never give up on doing the daily
work to improve the situation of ukraine
itself for your wider question
um i think we have to look at two points
um it is a wind down period
uh in six to eight months till the end
of the year so it's not an abrupt and
full speed
uh supply during that time and then
abrupt end but
a clear reduction of oil already
one
figure i have on the top of my head is
for example germany
told us that since the beginning of the
year where they started with 35 russian
oil they are already down to 12
russian oil this shows that by just
working hard on not renewing contracts
finishing contracts and looking at other
suppliers you can
fill this wind down period
much better and most importantly in the
back is of course the whole big package
of six sanctions and these sanctions are
biting hard
and
are really um destroying and that's the
the goal uh the basis the financial
basis um of putin leading this war and
hitting hard the russian economy
i would like to also say a few words
about that important question because i
think that when we were in versailles a
few weeks ago not many observers would
have thought that it would have been
possible for us only in a few weeks
to take such a concrete and strong
decision we have decided to sanctions
russia by banning
russian all this extremely important and
we will succeed in the following months
to implement that decision and ursula
is right when she said that it will
break the financing of the russian war
machine this is our goal and we have two
tools that we have that we are using as
much as we can on the one hand we
support ukraine with military equipment
with financial support with material
with political support as much as we can
also when we engage with third countries
in order to offer more support at the
international level point one and point
two we have decided on five packages of
sanctions and the last one was the the
the that we have decided yesterday
what's more difficult because this is
about energy and energy it's a big topic
it's a big thing for the members for the
households for the families for the
businesses and that's why we have
decided to work on solutions on concrete
solutions in order to make sure that the
decisions we are taking are painful for
russia for the kremlin this is our main
goal
daniel question philippe
um
[Music]
so what your question is concerned on
six package and the follow-up
i think
on one hand we have to look at the
russian economy and financial market
and on the other hand on uh the big
resources to the russian government that
is energy fossil fuel energy
and we have now clearly addressed
the three topics of coal oil and gas
with
two sanctioned packages
and repower eu
and the six sanctioned packages are also
of course addressing the financial
sector and
hurting it heavily the same goes for the
russian economy
and for me is important now after having
put in place the structure on the energy
element that we look in the financial
and the economic sector of russia
whether there are attempts of
circumventions now
or trying to move away from this
situation
and therefore i would not exclude that
we over and over will have to redress
the situation we address the situation
that we close loopholes that we stop
circumventions so that we keep on
working on that
but the big bulk on energy this is up
and running this is on the road in what
we've just described
um on the
food looming food crisis
that the fact that there is a severe
food crisis developing
is
only the fault of russia's unjustified
war
without this war we would not have it
and we should always over and over
repeat that um
russia is not only blocking the expert
of export of
ukrainian wheat it is bombarding
warehouses where wheat is stored
deliberately
of course you know that they are also
mining the fields where ukraine could
have the next harvest
of corn
and i want to be very clear we have no
sanctions on food and agricultural
products no sanctions on that
and important also if you is speaking
about fertilizers for example third
countries have access to all the
fertilizers for example from russia
this was a clear decision
that we say humanitarian goods and food
agriculture wheat of course is a part of
it
no sanctions on it so it's a complete
misinformation from russia's side the
only reason
why we are struggling now with the food
crisis is because of this brutal
unjustified war against ukraine
thank you madam presidents this
concludes our press conference it's a
matter of minutes for the publication of
the conclusions
you